call me dude Z now here are some YouTube
comments that I got uh that I'd like to
read from last week's episode this is
from o valencia229 oh man dude de
cursing and disappointment at Will's
muffin stunt was the best so yeah that's
why I'm dressed up like a chicken tender
platter this week because last week
dudesy had tasked us with making a vegan
muffin for one another I went to Whole
Foods and bought the [__] thing and
here I am dressed as a chicken tender uh
Derek verdonk eight nine four nine says
I love doozy's Newfound theater kid
energy
that's a perfect description yeah Samuel
butcher9352 says will said yum before he
could even taste the muffin
[Laughter]
that's some fat kid [__] I'm just gonna
let her said yum when I saw the muffin
yum